all right what's shaking not much man
can you hear me
loud and clear what can i do for you
tonight brother beautiful man i just
wanted to let you know
i've been watching your uh stuff for a
while and uh
it all kind of like just everybody in
the in uh you know rollo everybody
uh your story i'm actually in spokane
too uh which is kind of part of your
story which i didn't really realize
i researched but uh yeah um
bitterness and anger basically what hit
me was uh my one itis with my seven
uh when i was 17 i'm 31 now um
and uh it's taken me a long time to get
over
my one itis like it's just been crazy
i was 17 years old and uh she was like i
was like uh
like kind of like rollo you know
rockstar 20s but at 7
at 17 you know and uh
yeah she just basically lovebombed me
came in and just swooped me right from
the cradle she's like 22 a little older
you know and uh
yep and uh so why are you holding on to
that for so long like i don't know
man i don't know it's like i feel like i
might still be in love with her but then
get this dude she calls me back like
just recently probably like probably
actually a few years now but like
12 years after like married two kids
you know and looking at me like a sad
dog at the table
like just i couldn't like i just like
made her go to the store and get me a
six-pack because i was just i couldn't
even handle it you know what i mean
but you know what there's um
there's a game that i think a lot of
guys play
that are unwilling to admit it i mean
maybe they'll admit in the chat let's
see what happens but
yeah as you get in your 40s and your
values increase you've made money you've
taken care of yourself
you know you look good um you know
women vie for your attention men you
know
admire you sort of thing you start to
kind of look around and even on social
media
like you can do this you can go back to
your classroom picks from the last year
of high school and all those chicks that
you were hot to trot for
you would not even give them the time of
day today oh no for sure
and single moms falling apart they're
all single moms too man and it's like
it's like i can't even like it's weird
like looking at them like it is it's
just
there's it i don't know man yeah it's
the lens
it's all right that's why you never put
anybody up on a pedestal
there's nothing like everybody's
replaceable there's nothing special
yeah okay like okay fine like you might
get into a relationship with a woman
over a long term over a short term for a
lifetime who knows maybe she's special
maybe she's not but don't ever think
that somebody's not
replaceable everybody's replaceable and
that's true for anything in business i
mean steve jobs died they just replaced
oh we'll put this tim cook guy in his
place
let let him take over sort of thing
everybody's replaceable
you know what's weird too man is it like
it it changed my
attitude to that way it changed my
mentality which kind of sucks because it
like
and then it makes me like towards other
girls like defensive and like i've got
i've got other stuff i got to work on
now because of it you know let me ask
you a question
you're 31 you said yeah man yeah what
would you rate your
sexual market value out on a scale of 1
to 10 with 10 not very
good not good right now back in the day
it was up it was probably 10 for sure
but now
for now i wouldn't even
go yeah probably yeah like five
if maybe you know okay seriously
that would be a better place to
reallocate your energy and your focus
right is on you i mean it's got the best
payoff at the end of the day
yeah thinking about why she dumped you
when
you know when you're 17. thinking about
a bunch of other channels stuff like
watching
way too many videos not doing anything
there's a lot of um
red pill masturbation going on where
guys just like keep watching [ __ ] and
watching stuff and
you know they'll watch somebody else's
channel they'll watch this like and then
it turns into a red guy
yep guys don't yeah don't sit on the
sidelines just watching life go by man
do stuff
like that is like that is a before the
train wreck conversation is
a lot of guys sit around festering
masturbating over [ __ ] bad ideas from
the past or
bad ideas from somebody that gets no
results whatsoever
it's like man get off the sidelines and
live life and do some cool [ __ ]
right yeah man i paint houses for a
living dude and it's like [ __ ] i just
got i was on a roof today so i'm like
i'm making money right now but it's like
[ __ ]
i feel like i've wasted 10 years man i
painted houses for a living at one point
too i [ __ ] hated it
masking mat you know it's the same old
it's just like in the sun
it's all good it's what it is i know and
the [ __ ] foreman yells at you
and he doesn't pay you and it's like
where's my last hole
oh yeah yeah i know so okay but but
here's the difference i mean i came to
that realization
within a week of doing the job and i
[ __ ] stopped it
so why are you still doing it if you've
come to the same time no it's been way
too long
no and it sucks because i'm gonna have
to get past it because uh yeah
ten years like i've been in and out of
court too like in trouble
like doing some stupid [ __ ] like but i
mean i got all kinds of
stuff i could get on i don't want to
waste your time no but like you get the
point though right i mean like oh you're
in the driver's seat
of your life if you want to get better
results out of your life
then make some better inputs into it
right steer the [ __ ] vehicle in the
right direction and get away from [ __ ]
like
hey painting houses is okay i can make
some money at it but this is [ __ ]
[ __ ] this i'm going over here yeah
music's where it's at for me man
and actually that's but it's not
realistic though too
you know it's kind of one of them things
too you get the point though right
absolutely all right man i'll let you go
all right rich today bro
later buddy
you